here's what's in theaters this weekend a  man's daughter is the center of his  universe James Franco and Bryan Cranston  team up and why him an edgy comedy about  a fathers rivalry with his daughter's  billionaire boyfriend in the  breathtaking fantasy film a monster  calls a boy embarks on a life-changing  journey of loss courage and faith roof  over your head yes sir got clothes on  your back yes sir why you think that is  the drama fences takes a cold hard look  at race relations in the 1950s through  the eyes of a struggling family here's  this week's fantasy patient so what's  your weekend ticket going to be let us  know by commenting below see you next  time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]